[Musique]
Darlan le troisième homme de Vichy
documentaire en forme de portrait
réalisé par Jérôme prieur l'occasion
vous venez de le voir de découvrir ou
redécouvrir celui qui était le dauphin
officiel du Maréchal Pétain et qui
délivère 1941 a mis en œuvre avec zèle
la politique de collaboration souhaitée
par ce dernier avec l'Allemagne nazie et
pour revenir sur le rôle clé qui aura
exercé d'Arlan durant cette sombre
période de la collaboration avec nous
maintenant sur ce plateau debadoc
Isabelle d'avion bienvenue à vous
Isabelle d'avion vous êtes historienne
maîtresse de conférence à Sorbonne
université en histoire contemporaine des
pays germaniques qui est de l'Europe
centre orientale chercheuse associée au
service historiques de la défense par
ailleurs et c'est vous qui étiez la
conseillère historique sur ce
documentaire de Jérôme prieur première
question peut-être parce que on a envie
de comprendre comment un républicain un
homme venu du centre gauche comme on
était d'Arlon n'arrive-t-il à devenir le
numéro 2 du régime de Vichy et le
dauphin officiel de Philippe Pétain oui
alors effectivement on peut même trouver
ça un petit peu déprimant par ailleurs
mais d'Arlanc c'est un pur produit de la
République alors cela dit attention
c'est un carriériste ce n'est pas un
idéologue il faut vraiment le voir comme
un homme qui n'a aucune colonne
vertébrale et qui donc peut se couler
dans n'importe quel moule alors il faut
lire la biographie de Bernard
Costagliola à son sujet mais d'Arlanc
c'est le fils d'un député républicain
enfin voilà d'un homme politique de la
Troisième République
d'ailleurs qui était franc-maçon et
d'Arlon a très largement bénéficié du
carnet d'adresses de son père et c'est
sans doute l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles il est choisi par Bloom pour
être mis à la tête de la flotte c'est à
dire pour être nommé ce que l'on appelle
le pacha de la marine mais il travaille
avant tout à sa propre carrière ça c'est
un ça c'était un point très important
c'est un opportuniste du début à la fin
dans ce film on y reviendra d'ailleurs
enfin c'est une un trait de caractère
qu'on semble bien comprendre à travers à
travers le film qu'on vient de voir en
d'Arlan il y a une infinité
particulière entre les deux hommes oui
alors je rêve d'abord si vous ne
permettez revenir sur cette notion
d'opportunisme qui me paraît très
important parce que trop souvent on a
tendance à présenter d'argent comme un
pragmatique c'est à dire voilà quelqu'un
qui gère les dossiers jour après jour
mais c'est pas seulement du pragmatisme
c'est pas seulement de la réal politique
puisque il entend tiré bénéfice
personnellement du fait de se
positionner aux côtés du vainqueur du
moment voilà il n'est pas seulement le
jouet passif de celui qui est le
vainqueur allemand puis américain etc
donc je vraiment j'insiste sur cette
opportuniste
la suite oui oui complètement
Bénédicte Vergès le montre bien dans le
film que nous avons vu c'est à dire que
ce sont deux hommes qui qui viennent
dans le fond de du mamie au Cercle pas
du même milieu politique mais ce que
j'ai c'est que ce sont deux officiers de
carrière qui ont côtoyé des hommes de
gouvernement par ailleurs
en fait ils étaient faits pour
s'entendre parce que Pétain n'aime rien
tant que lire des notes écrites et
d'Arlan n'aime rien tant qu'en rédiger
donc si vous les mettez vraiment faits
pour travailler ensemble alors après
au-delà de ça l'entente est bien moindre
qu'entre Pétain et Laval déjà et puis
par ailleurs il y a évidemment une
bataille d'ego entre les deux hommes
c'est à dire que dans tout ce culte de
la personnalité autour de Pétain tel que
nous l'avons vu d'ailleurs à l'instant
c'est darlon essaie d'exister finalement
dans cette propagande et en même temps
Darlan c'est très bien qu'il est en
poste grâce au soutien de Pétain dont
tout ceci est très ambigu et alors
Pétain qui n'a aucune loyauté lorsqu'il
s'agira de lâcher d'Arlon il le fera
mais sans état d'âme pour autant il va
le nommer comme étant son successeur
désigné processeur officiel il avait
donc une certaine confiance en darlante
bien sûr non non il y avait une
confiance et il y avait un modus vivendi
très très bien établi on le voit bien
d'ailleurs dans les images c'est-à-dire
que en fait Pétain ne fait pas grand
chose à part exister dans l'image sortir
rentrer signer des petites photos etc
celui qui travaille c'est Darlan et puis
à un moment donné c'est bien dit dans le
film il devient ministre de tout avant
de parler de ce qu'on a fait d'Arlan en
tant que vice-président du conseil à
partir de février 41
expliquez-moi tout de même pourquoi il
nous est dit dans ce film que dans les
journées
tragiques
du 14 15 16 juin 17 juin 1940 Pétain
d’arlan pardon semble hésiter sur le
camp à regagné et finalement il choisit
celui de Pétain et du régime de Vichy
pourquoi est-ce que il a hésité et
pourquoi il a choisi ce camp final dans
ces journées tragiques effectivement je
crois que c'est un point assez fort du
film en ce moment donc Bernard
costaliola en parle du fait que darlon
c'est un homme qui aurait pu changer les
seins de la France il a trouvé
différents éléments différentes sources
qui une fois croisées alors amen à ses
hésitations de Darlan en 40 alors on a
effectivement Jules moque qui est alors
qui est député socialisme et qui est
surtout ingénieur maritime et donc à ce
titre un proche de d'Arlon on a
également boutillé qui était ministre
des Finances de Vichy et surtout le
ministre dont d'Arlon est le plus proche
durant sa vice-président ont plein de de
sources qui concordent pour dire que et
bien il hésite lors de ces jours
fatidiques notamment 15 16 juin 1940 il
hésite à repartir en guerre avec la
flotte alors vous dire pourquoi
finalement il choisit il choisit le
destin voilà que on nous dit dans ce
film c'est parce qu'on lui propose un
ministère qui n'a jamais eu que le
ministère de la Marine et qu'il obtien
en rejoignant Pétain alors c'est vrai
alors de toute façon là on touche à
l'humain la réponse exacte on ne l'aura
jamais tout ce que l'on peut dire et
c'est déjà pas mal c'est que
premièrement pépin lui a promis un poste
et c'est ne perspective qu'il en chante
deuxièmement il est vrai que comme on le
sait la flotte française et ressortie à
peu près intacte de la de la débâcle et
il s'inquiète de savoir si cette flotte
tiendrait bon au cas où il repartira en
guerre avec ce que je peux dire c'est
que que ce soit sa carrière que ce soit
l'état de la flotte ou je ne sais quoi
il y a quelque chose que d'Arlan a passé
plus haut que l'honneur de son pays
lorsqu'il se voit donc nommé
vice-président du Conseil numéro 2 du
régime le 9 février 41 est-ce que la
politique de collaboration avec
l'Allemagne nazie est déjà concrètement
engagée ou est-ce que c'est lui qui le
langage nous sommes bien sûr après
montoir l'entrevue entre Pétain et
Hitler effectivement comme vous le dites
la collaboration est déjà engagée il y a
déjà eu mon toit mais je dirais qu'en
partie déjà ce que apporte d'argent
c'est que lui est pour une collaboration
politique et économique en échange de
contrepartie c'est à dire qu'ils croient
en ce que l'on pourra appeler une
collaboration marchandage de son côté
Hitler a tout intérêt à laisser croire
aux Français qu'ils ont une marge de
négociation ce qui est absolument faux
donc de ce point de vue si il y a cette
rencontre et d'Arlan ne cesse de faire
des propositions dès l'automne 1940 il
propose une opération militaire
conjointe de la France en direction des
colonies britanniques il le fera jusqu'à
la fin 1941 ou encore il propose une
intervention de Vichy contre contre le
Tchad et les colonies enfin le chat de
Gauliste et les colonies britanniques
d'Afrique de l'Est
en Syrie d'ailleurs aux Allemands on
fournira de l'artillerie des armes
notamment en Syrie après ce qui s'est
passé en Irak qui se retourne en réalité
contre la Syrie ça c'est le temps fort
du gouvernement d'Arlon à sont les
protocoles de mai juin 1940 il y a une
collaboration
avec la caution de Pétain oui tout à
fait par ailleurs comme les Allemands
ont un besoin très fort en camion
essence notamment pour l'Afrique accords
de Romel tout ça fonctionne très très
bien donc de ce point de vue si c'est
important de comprendre que c'est
vraiment Darlan qui pose les bases de la
politique de Laval appartient de 1942 et
il y a une chose qui est très importante
également c'est que la plus grande
proposition de collaboration est faite
par Darlan juste après le déclenchement
de l'opération de Barbara Rosa c'est son
mémorandum du 14 juillet 1941 où là il
propose carrément une alliance militaire
au Troisième Reich alors fort
heureusement Hitler ne saisit pas le
bénéfice énorme qu'il pouvait tirer
d'une offre qui néglige parce qu'il est
occupé en Union soviétique qui plus est
après avoir lancé cette cette asso en
Union soviétique et cette fameuse
opération
Barbarossa ça aurait été un mirage aux
alouettes cette politique de
collaboration pour pour darl un vrai
échec collaboration militaire j'entends
qu'il arrive à un moment donné je pense
qu'il a il a eu le sentiment d'avoir
obtenu des concessions parce que les
Allemands sont très forts pour faire
croire que on a des cartes en main alors
qu'on a les mains absolument vides donc
il se dit sans doute qu'il a obtenu des
choses en revanche en 1942 il sent aussi
que il n'a plus rien à monnayer parce
qu'il y a plus la ligne de démarcation
était traversée il y a plus d'empire il
y a plus donc là il sent que le moment
du grand virage est arrivé alors on
apprend aussi dans ce film que d'Arlan
est particulièrement anglophone
d'où vient cet anglophobie est-ce que ça
justifie pleinement cette volonté de
collaboration avec avec l'Allemagne pour
une Europe nouvelle
la justifie elle vient l'habiller en
tout cas mais en revanche ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que quand même il y a une
sincérité de l'anglophobie au départ et
qui est celle d'une génération de
l'entre-deux-guerres qui est celle plus
particulièrement d'une grande partie de
l'état-major à l'intérieur de cet
état-major d'une grande partie de la
marine alors se nourri par quoi d'une
part déjà par les années 20 où on a
l'impression que la Grande-Bretagne nous
a fait défaut sur les réparations nous a
fait des promesses fallacieuses
d'alliance militaire qu'on n'a jamais vu
ce pointer à l'horizon par ailleurs il y
a les années 30 également où les
Britanniques intervenaient que pour nous
dicter leurs conditions c'est ce qu'on
appelle la gouvernante anglaise English
Nani et puis je dirais que les marins
ont pris bonne note de l'accord naval
anglo-allemand de 1935 qui est venu
faire éclater le front de Stresa un
front diplomatique était censé garantir
de traiter de Versailles et puis bien
sûr par dessus tout ça il y a merci le
Kebir le 3 juillet 1940
et au tout début du mois de juillet 1940
bien l'Angleterre les Britanniques
décident d'attaquer une partie de notre
flotte c'est bon c'est presque préventif
comme attaque mais ça coûtera la vie à
1295 marins français et effectivement
Darlan se souv toujours et se souviendra
toujours de cet épisode durant toute sa
carrière oui d'ailleurs on représaille
d'argent propose à la marine italienne
un raid de combiné en Égypte sur
Alexandrie je revois je reviens sur le
plan intérieur d'Arlan et les lois
juives en quoi a-t-il mis en œuvre cette
politique anti juive c'est loi anti
juive dont il est tout de même l'auteur
effectivement la persécution
déjà commencé en juillet 1942 et lors du
gouvernement d'Arlan nous avons en mars
41 la mise en place du commissariat aux
questions juives qui est un instrument
d'encadrement puis de persécution des
Juifs par ailleurs et nous venons de le
voir dans le film la première rafle
massive de Juifs c'est celle du billet
vert le 14 mai 1941 vous avez également
en juin 1941 le deuxième statut des
juifs avec également un recensement ça
signifie de nouveaux interdits
professionnels ça signifie également des
mesures d'internement dans des camps
spéciaux des mesures de spoliation et
puis le gouvernement n'a jamais rien
fait pour tenter de freiner les
arrestations de Juifs par les Allemands
à Paris en décembre 1941 mais par
ailleurs si je puis me permettre il y a
une archive que moi je trouve
particulièrement accablante pour Darlan
on pourrait passer à côté c'est une
lettre qu'il consigne avec Jérôme
Carcopino qui à l'époque est de
l'éducation et à la jeunesse une lettre
qu'ils envoient à Pétain en juin 1941 où
il demande l'établissement d'un humérus
clausus à l'université qui commencerait
par 3% en médecine etc donc qu'est-ce
que cela signifie cela signifie que
d'Arlan demande la mise en place de loi
d'exception qui signe l'antisémitisme
d'État sans aucune intervention
allemande sans aucune intervention
allemande puis vous l'avez dit il y a eu
ce recensement en zone libre ça c'est
son initiative mais ces ressourcement
coûtera très cher à un bon nombre de
Juifs sur le territoire à la fois en
zone libre et en zone en zone occupée et
puis il y a cette loi sur la spoliation
décrit sur l'exposition des biens juifs
tout ça on le doit alors et c'est assez
bien dit d'ailleurs dans ce dans ce
documentaire et puis arrive l'opération
torche la fameuse opération torche se
débarquement alliée sur les côtes
d'Afrique du Nord et notamment à Alger
où se trouve Darlan par hasard parce
qu'on lui a dit que son fils était
mourant et donc il se rend sur place et
c'est durant
cette visite à Alger de Darlan qui
arrive se débarquement
allié alors et là il arrive à retourner
la situation et c'est là qu'on voit un
Darlan
commencé à à changer sa veste de côté
oui alors présence par hasard ou non bon
mais dans tous les cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que les Américains ont d'abord
contacté Giraud pour diriger
l'administration
mais Giro exige d'avoir le commandement
de l'intervention alliée donc bon il se
tourne vers d'Arlon ça c'est important
de le noter ça que pour les Américains
d'Arlon c'est pas le premier choix c'est
le dernier recours alors pourquoi Darlan
c'est parce qu'il a une autorité qui est
légitime il est quand même chef des
forces militaires et puis il a été un
dirigeant de Vichy donc il compte sur
lui pour sécuriser le passage des trous
parce que la priorité pour les
américains c'est la Tunisie où ils
doivent rencontrer les Allemands si je
puis dire et par ailleurs les officiers
français veulent l'accord de Darlan pour
signer le cesser et d’arlan il voit la
possibilité de et bien de se placer de
monter sur ce char aussi et donc par
ailleurs il veut faire reconnaître par
les Américains le maintien de la
législation anti juive de Vichy en
Afrique du Nord et le maintien des
fonctionnaires en place pourquoi pour
empêcher Giro de monter en grade et il
faudra attendre la mie 1943 pour que
l'aborgation notamment un logo Crémieu
soit effective du côté de de l'Algérie
d'Arlan est assassiné le 24 décembre
1942 il aura donc pas à rendre compte
par définition à la fin de la guerre de
ses actes
et il est assassiné par Fernand Bonnier
de la chapelle mais qui a armé Fernand
Bonnier de la chapelle c'est toute la
question elle est posée à la fin du
documentaire et semble-t-il on a
toujours pas la réponse aujourd'hui qui
a assassiné à commanditer cette
assassinat d'argent
on en a une meilleure idée aujourd'hui
non je vais vous renvoyer la question
telle que le fait Bénédicte Vergès c'est
qui n'a pas intérêt à se débarrasser de
Darlan en fait c'est à dire que on a de
moins en moins la réponse parce que plus
on fouille plus la liste des suspects
s'allonge on peut la faire ensemble
cette liste des suspects néanmoins les
gaullistes oui les Américains
probablement c'est-à-dire que les plus
folles conspirations sont imaginés et
notamment alors on a mentionné le compte
de Paris qui aurait donné son accord de
Gaulle également mais tout ceci dans le
fond n'est pas très crédible notamment
d'ailleurs si l'on prend en compte la
surprise qui a été à Londres
l'assassinat de Darlan mais l'histoire
c'est l'art de la preuve il n'y a rien
dans les archives donc c'est une
question qui sans doute n'aura jamais de
réponse merci beaucoup en tout cas
Isabelle d'avion d'avoir été avec nous
pour participer à ce débat doc consacré
à François Darlan merci aussi à sel
massali qui était à l'édition de cette
émission aujourd'hui vos réactions ça
sera bien sûr sur hashtag des bad sur
Twitter puis je vous dis tout simplement
à très bientôt ça pour un autre débat
doc avec bien entendu son documentaire
et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]